[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 24 janvier voici le
programme de ce soir une action coup de
point pour se faire entendre 13
tracteurs se sont rassemblés tôt ce
matin pour déposer des de paille sur la
N12 au niveau de Houdan les Yvelines
rejoignent ainsi le mouvement national
des agriculteurs en colère d'autres
actions sont annoncé dans les prochains
jours on fait le point kmat la première
usine de cœur artificiel au monde
souhaite augmenter sa production située
à Bois d'Arcy la société a déjà
transplanté ses cœurs en Allemagne et en
Italie mais aimerait s'étendre aux
États-Unis son ambition atteindre la
production de 1000 cœur artificiel par
an d'ici 2020 27 chaque année les
ovmpiades reviennent à la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet l'objectif de
ce concours sélectionner les meilleurs
jeunes berger et valoriser le métier
d'éleveur de brebis ils étaient une
trentaine de candidats retour sur cet
événement et puis comme d'habitude
l'invité du 78 en 2uxè partie d'émission
ce soir nous serons avec Sonia Bro la
mère de saint-sir l'école elle viendra
nous présenter les grands projet pour
l'année à venir dans sa commune vous
connaissez le programme bienvenue dans
votre suite tout de suite les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir On commence ces
informations du jour avec la colère des
agriculteurs yvelinois il dénonce
notamment l'inflation dont ils sont
victimes ainsi que les contraintes
européennes liées à la profession ce
matin une première action a eu lieu dans
les Yvelines oui Mathilde et la colère
ne faiblit pas peu avant 8h30 une
opération escargot a eu lieu dans le
secteur de Oudan à l'appel du syndicat
FS FDSEA Île-de-France une trentaine
d'agriculteurs se sont rassemblé sur la
nationale 12 pas de blocage des routes
mais un arrêt pour accrocher une
banderole avec l'inscription suivante
Macron répond-nous hashtag sauf ton
paysan de radars ont également été
couverts de pailles c'est la première
fois depuis le début de la mobilisation
que des agriculteurs se mobilisent dans
la région une nouvelle opération est
prévue demain matin sur la nationale 12
cette fois-ci dans le secteur de
Montfort lamoris Frédéric rose pourrait
devenir le nouveau préfet des Yvelines
oui il s'agit d'une information du média
la lettre Frédéric rose actuel
conseiller intérieur et sécurité
d'Emmanuel Macron et ancien proche
collaborateur de Rachida Dati pourrait
succéder à Jean-Jacques Brux l'actuel
préfet des Yvelines depuis 2018
cependant cette nomination Mathilde
n'est pas encore officielle il faudra
attendre une officialisation en Conseil
des ministres on poursuit Gabriel avec
une information spatiale oui il y a 3
ans jour pour jour une fusée Falcon 9
était lancé par SpaceX en Floride 143
satellites étaient à bord parmi eux
uvsqsat il s'agissait du tout premier
nano satellite français destiné à
observer des variables climatiques il a
entièrement été conçu au laboratoire du
Latmos à Guy en courours depuis son
lancement uvsqusat a effectué plus de
15000 tours de la terre fourni plus de
20 millions de les mesures livré plus de
3 millions de données scientifiques on
peut voir quelques exemples à l'image en
avril 2023 UVSQ satat a été rejoint par
un deuxième nano satellite celui-ci il
s'appelle inspire sat 7 1 3e devrait
arriver sera lancé en 2025 c'est cubsat
uvsqsat NG
184 jours avant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris et pour l'occasion la ville de
poissie s'organise oui mathde car
plusieurs stars du triathlon poseront
leurs valises dans la cité Saint-Louis à
poissie parmi elles le Norvégien Christi
Christian Blumenfeld double médaillé
d'or au Jeux de Tokyo et la bermudienne
Flora Jane deffy d'autres athlètes
néozélandais et suisses devraient
également s'y installer pour leurs
entraînements le stade Léo larange et la
piscine de mot seront mis à leur
disposition et poiss pourrait également
accueillir l'été prochain un autre sport
olympique le rudby A7 l'équipe japonaise
serait déjà en contact avec la
municipalité enfin Gabriel on termine
avec de la danse le groupe noblas crew
fait la gloire des Yvelines oui dimanche
dernier le club de danse originaire de
Mantel Jolie a triomphé pour la deuxème
année consécutif il remporte le battle
age quality une compétition française de
danse HP hop composée de deux épreuves
l'une en groupe et l'autre en duo je
vous propose qu'on regarde un
extrait
[Musique]
et vous le voyez sur ces images noblas
Crew a tout raflé les ivelinois
repartent donc avec une récompense de
2024 €. 2024 € pour l'année 2024
peut-être comme l'année effectivement
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
news en 2013 l'entreprise kmat située à
boî d'Arcy implanté pour la première
fois un cœur artificiel un humain
aujourd'hui l'objectif pour la société
est d'étendre sa production à travers le
monde c'est le reportage de Patrick
Jacques de dixmut et de Gabriel
Gontier il y a 10 ans l'entreprise skmat
permettait l'implantation du tout
premier cœur artificiel au monde
aujourd'hui la technologie conçue à Bois
d'Arcy a permis d'équiper une
cinquantaine de patients l'objectif de
renavant augmenter la production et la
commercialisation pour répondre à la
crise de l'insuffisance cardiaque lié au
manque de greffon aujourd'hui on est à
peu près sur une augmentation de d'année
en année de l'ordre de on double notre
production d'année en année c'est un peu
l'objectif qu'on a en terme d'ordre
d'idée alors ça varie évidemment par
rapport à la demande hein puisque on est
on s'aligne aussi sur la demande c'estàd
qu'on est capable d'accélérer
éventuellement si on le souhaite c'est
c'est clairement lié aux éthiques
commerciales et à leurs besoins déjà
présent en Allemagne et en Italie les
cœurs carat devrai se développer en
France et aux États-Unis d'ici 2027
notre objectif c'est les États-Unis on
se prépare donc parce que aux États-Unis
on sait que c'est le marché majeur de la
cardiologie mondiale dans tous les
domaines de la cardiologie de ce fait là
il faut que nous on soit prêt et c'est
ce qu'on fait leader dans cette
technologie après plus de 10 ans de
développement et de recherche dans ses
usines la technologie est en constant
développement sur le site de Bois d'Arcy
où sont assemblés les cœurs artificiels
on arrive à un moment où la prothèse a
beaucoup progresser en fiabilité
globalement on arrive sur quelque chose
extrêmement pointu c'est sans doute ce
qu'on appelle le divice ou le système
médical le plus pointu qui existe au
monde puisque ça ne tolère aucune
défaillance puisque c'est le cœur et
vous savez que sil y a une défaillance
malheureusement ça se passe mal
l'ouverture au marchés internationaux
est aujourd'hui nécessaire à
l'entreprise pour atteindre son
équilibre financier cette année le site
devrait réaliser une centaine
d'implantations direction à présent la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet hier
se déroulait la finale du meilleur jeune
berger d'île-de-fance une trentaine de
candidats se sont affrontés à travers
des épreuves théoriques et pratiques
l'objectif susciter des vocations et
donner envie à une nouvelle génération
de s'installer en élevage de brebis
regardez trier les
brebis évaluer leur état de
santé ou encore parer des onglons en
cette matinée hivernale il sont une
trentaine à tenter de devenir le
meilleur jeune berger d'île-de France
parmi eux une quinzaine de la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet et pour la
première fois cette année une quinzaine
du centre de formation agricole la
Bretonnière en scèar ça fait une
expérience en plus et ça me permet
d'apprendre aussi les moutons parce que
je suis pas du tout dans le milieu voilà
ça permet d'apprendre et ça fait une
bonne journée c'est convivial les
éleveurs sont assez patients ils
prennent le temps aussi ils ont
conscience aussi qu'on est voilà qu'on
est jeune qu'on est là aussi pour
apprendre don ils sont très pédagogues
prennent le temps d'évaluer de de voir
un peu aussi notre aisence avec la
manipulation de l'animal mais aussi de
pouvoir expliquer nos connaissances donc
c'est très intéressant et c'est une très
bonne expérience et pour devenir le
meilleur jeune berger d'Île-de- France
il faut réussir les épreuves théoriques
et pratiques ces dernières sont
directement inspiré des gestes
quotidiens des éleveurs vous avez l'état
d'engraissement des agneaux donc c'est
une épreuve importante puisque c'est on
juge l'état des annaux avant des vendre
donc c'est le revenu de l'éleveur le tri
des brebis bah c'est c'est pareil c'est
une épreuve d'éleveur donc trier des
brobilles selon ce qu'on demande la
génétique c'est pour le choix des
reproducteurs donc c'est pareil c'est
pour le revenu puis améliorer la qualité
de l'élevage et la santé animale bah
c'est le B àas de tous les jours mais
ces ovinpièes ont avant tout pour
objectif de susciter des vocations chez
la jeune génération la filière recrute
dans tous les domaines c'est une vitrine
pour notre métier ça permet de de
montrer que notre filière est dynamique
et que des jeunes s'intéressent encore à
l'élevage au vin ça mobilise les jeunes
ça permet de se rencontrer et et
vraiment pour les jeunes ça ouvre plein
de portes ça permet de de rencontrer du
monde de trouver potentiellement de
l'emploi des mettes de stage et cetera
des formations adaptées et ce travail
sur le long terme commence à porter ses
fruits selon le recensement général
agricole de 2020 le départ de 500
éleveurs est compensé par 500
installations chaque année soit un
départ pour une arrivée prochaine étape
pour ces olympiades 2024 la finale
nationale au salon de l'agriculture le
24 février Alexia hurtevent et Amélie
lamperrière auront la chance de
concourir au titre de meilleur jeune
berger de
France et pour la première fois la
France relance des ovmpiades
internationale une trentaine de
délégations étrangères participeront à
la 3e Coupe du Monde du meilleur jeune
berger du monde ce sera du 25 mai au 1er
juin la compétition fera étape à la
Bergerie Nationale et on reste à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
puisque ce samedi 27 janvier le site
organise ses journées portes ouvertes
vous y retrouverez toutes les
informations sur les métiers de
l'agriculture du cheval et de la santé
animale la Bergerie nationale propose 16
formations qui vont du cap à la licence
[Musique]
professionnelle il y a deux journées
portes ouvertes pour le pôle formation
il y en a une ce samedi euh donc le 27
janvier et il y en aura une deuxème un
autre samedi qui sera le 9 mars
[Musique]
2024 l'idée c'est vraiment d'accueillir
les futurs apprentis et stagiaires de la
formation continue qui viendront dans
nos formations plus tard et de leur à la
fois de leur donner des informations
collectives en particulier sur
l'apprentissage puisqu'on a la
particularité d'être un centre
d'apprentissage ou sur les financements
des formations pour les adultes par
exemple
[Musique]
exemple beaucoup de formations épiqu
donc lié au métier du cheval que ce soit
l'enseignement ou la gestion de
structures épique on a des formations
liées à l'agriculture bien entendu hein
puisqu'on est un établissement
d'enseignement agricole avec en
particulier des BTS production animale
et gestion et stratégie de
l'exploitation agricole et ça c'est très
important parce que dans les années à
venir va y avoir un fort fort
renouvellement des générations
d'agriculteurs
alors c'est un établissement très
singulier hein d'abord parce que au
niveau historique c'est quand même des
des conditions d'accueil dans un dans un
milieu remarquable que ce soit les
bâtiments le
parc c'est comme tout l'enseignement
agricool on a la particularité de
proposer des internats donc 75 % de nos
apprenants sont internes des 400
apprenants de de du centre de formation
sont
internes
et c'est bientôt l'heure de passer à
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions avoir
la tête dans les nuage sur l'ensemble
des Yvelines le brouillard sera bien
présent côté température de la douceur
il fera entre 9 et 10°r l'après-midi le
brouillard devrait laisser place à la
pluie dans le département niveau
température il fera 13 de du côté de
Mantel jolie et de houdans et 12°gr vers
Versailles et rambouillé et demain nous
fêterons la saint-pul c'est l'heure à
présent de l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir nous serons avec la mère
de saint-cire l'école Sonia Bro bonsoir
bonsoir bonne année 2024 bonne année à
vous aussi à tous ceux qui vous sont
précieux merci bonne année également à
tous les saint-syiens et les
saint-syriennes première question Sonia
brro quel bilan faites-vous de l'année
2023 à saincir l'école que retenez-vous
de cette année
écoulée alors une année compliquée
perturbante
euh plus sur un retentissement national
qui a touché l'ensemble de nos communes
mais à la fois une année où bah les
projets ont avancé où on on peut dès
2024 se projeter sur des fins de
chantier et et l'un dans l'autre
finalement la vie reprend son cours vous
parliez des des émeutes urbaines je
parle des émeut je parle de de
l'inflation sur sur une ville où on a
encore 33 % de logements sociaux avec
une énergie qui qui a pris un bon
incroyable un panier de course qui est
de plus en plus compliqué à assurer
jusqu'à la fin du mois non non je pense
que au niveau national les retombé sur
nos territoires ce qui est normal ont
été assez important
justement avec ce contexte compliqué
d'inflation de crise énergétique on sait
que c'est compliqué pour les finances
des collectivités est-ce qu'à cause de
ce contexte compliqué vous allez devoir
augmenter les impôts locaux dans votre
ville alors nous nous n'augmenterons pas
les impôts locaux enfin cette année en
tous les cas je ne préjure jamais de
rien parce que je suis élu depuis 2008
et j'ai vécu des crises comme cell de
2016 qui étaient quand même pas
mal je suis aussi conseillère
départemental
et au niveau du département aujourd'hui
on vit une crise absolument
ubuesque le département c'est le premier
partenaire de la ville donc quand lui il
a moins d'argent qu'est-ce qu'il fait de
son argent il le redistribue aux
collectivités aux villes bon ben ça veut
dire qu'on sait pertinemment qu'il va
falloir avoir on va dire un à 2 ans
minimum si tout restait comme ça assez
compliqué mais nous avons fait le choix
de ne pas augmenter les impôts ça veut
dire qu'on sera beaucoup plus
drastique sur la gestion du quotidien
alors alors dans les grands projets pour
la commune depuis plusieurs années déjà
il y a le renouvellement du quartier de
la Fontaine Saint-Martin qu'est-ce qui
est prévu concrètement et où en sont les
travaux alors c'est en effet un grand
grand projet c'est un projet qui a qui
s'est initié en 2016 vous voyez comme le
temps de de de la rénovation est longue
ça a commencé réellement on a commencé à
avoir des échafaudages il y a il y a 2
ans à peu près ça prend du temps parce
que c'est une énorme rénovation c'est
qu'on a fait le choix avec le bailleur
et avec le département de ne pas faire
une rénovation classique avec un peu
d'isolation à
l'extérieur des mises au normme au
niveau électrique mais de revoir
entièrement l'intégralité des
appartements que ce soit au niveau des
mobiliers salle de bain cuisine
évidemment toutes les mises aux normes
électrique et extérieur pour l'isolation
parce que justement on on le disait tout
à l'heure l'énergie la consommation est
une vraie problématique aujourd'hui pour
les foyers et notamment pour les foyers
modestes en conséquence de quoi une
meilleure isolation bah c'est forcément
un gain pour le locataire et un travail
vraiment partenarial entre la ville et
le bailleur puisque ce sont des
bâtiments qui datent des années 70 une
époque dans laquelle on construisait
avec des espaces public ouvert qui
s'entremêl entre ce qui appartenait au
bailleur ce qui appartenait à la à la
commune et donc une une meilleure
résidentialisation des bâtiments des
places de parking de façon à
assurer une une envie d'être chez soi
pour les personnes qui habitent le
quartier ça concerne combien d'habitants
environ ce qutier alors c'est un peu
moins de 1000 logements donc à peu près
allez 1700 2000 2000 personnes et ça
représente quel coût pour la ville ce
grand projet de renouvement urbain alors
je
je ça représente le projet en totalité
représente 76 million d'euros pour la
ville il y a à peu près 5 à 6 millions
d'euros puisque ça se traduit par les
voiries vraiment des changement de
circulation dans le quartier même pour
l'ouvrir sur la ville toujours dans les
grands projets pour la ville la mise en
place de la zone commercial baptisé les
portes de saint-cir qui est située à
côté de la ferme de Gal plusieurs
commerçants ont ouvert depuis quelques
mois lesquels et quels sont ceux qui
vont arriver prochainement alors c'est
c'est un projet qui date de
83 c'est comme quoi quand on dit que le
temps est long oui parce que l'aérodome
était plutôt contre était plutôt contte
parce qu'ils avaient très très peur que
une zone commerciale amenant du monde on
finisse par dire ben on va fermer
l'aérodrome la création de cette zone
d'activité euh permet justement
beaucoup de facilité par rapport à ses
habitants on a par exemple bon l'atelier
des papis qui est une boulangerie on a
Culture Vélo qui est quelque chose qui
était extrêmement demandé sur Saint-
cire c'està-dire un magasin où on peut
acheter de l'article de vélo mais qui
soit un professionnel on a la ménagerie
du roi qui s'est installée qui est les
la Brasserie du roi de de Versailles qui
avait besoin d'espace pour pouvoir
fabriquer sa bière une salle de sport
voilà des des cabinets dentaires et ça
va apporter de la vie et une bque
populaire et quelles sont les prochaines
entreprises qui vont s'implanter alors
aujourd'hui tout est en discussion
d'accord on n pas on n pas trop
d'information on me parle d'un
McDonald's bon de toute façon on a
cetteouô alors moi je vais vous dire à
la base je suis une libérale donc le
fait que McDonald's veuille s'implanter
à sainciè donne une image d'une ville
qui est quand même dynamique
généralement McDonald's ne va pas
s'installer à un endroit où il a pas la
capacité de développement d'une
clientèle on a cette grande chance à
sainir d'être protégé par les ABF h donc
même si c'est McDonald's qui
s'installent ce sera avec des codes
architecturaux qui
répondront à la proximité du château
j'ai envie de dire qu'on a on a plutôt
des atouts alors 2024 sera aussi marqué
par la rénovation de nombreuses routes
qui ont déjà commencé notamment bah
celle qui va longer enfin celle qui
longe cette nouvelle zone commerciale
les portes de qui est déjà en
renouvellement d'autres routes vont être
rénovées alors oui on est en train de de
terminer alors cette année les routes
cétaient beaucoup aux alentours de la
RD7 he cette cette grande départementale
qui longe l'arrière du château qui vont
accueillir les les Jeux Olympiques et
notamment la partie éestre triathlon et
autres et donc en fait on a travaillé à
la fois sur cette RD7 via le département
mais aussi sur les parallèles on a par
exemple l'avenue du colonel Arnaud
beltrin qui est une route qui appartient
à la zone à la
zone Charles renard qui n'était pas
encore terminé et que nous sommes en
train de terminer pour venir se
raccorder à l' RD7 puis la route qui
s'appelle la rue guimokeé qui elle-même
a deux perpendiculaires de petites
routes en impasse et qui est un quartier
très résidentiel et il aurait été
insupportable d'avoir une RD7
complètement rénovée pour des Jeux
Olympiques et que la commune ne rénove
pas une route dans laquelle on a une une
petite centaine de pavillons et donc de
saint-sirien qui attendaient ses
rénovations donc les travaux seront
finis avant les Jeux Olympiques c'est un
impératif alors pas pour la rue guimoet
d'accord parce que ce sont des des
travaux qui vont prendre un peu plus de
temps et que on se donne le temps la RD7
le sera et le l'avenue du du colonel
Beltram aussi alors un projet sur le
laquel vous travaillez depuis 6 ans
c'est la mise en place d'un accueil
unique qu'est-ce que c'est l'objectif
c'est de simplifier la vie du
saint-érien qu'il n'est pas à courir sur
plusieurs rendez-vous qu'on n pas une
première étape où on dit j'ai entendu
que vous pouviez pas payer ce mois-ci ne
vous inquiétez pas on l'a noté prenez
rendez-vous à tel endroit avec tel
service non il faut qu'on arrive à une
telle fluidité que dans la la matinée
l'après-midi les choses soient soient
bouclées alors 2024 Sonia Bros c'est
aussi l'année des Jeux Olympiques on en
a parlé un petit peu est-ce que vous
avez prévu des animations avant les Jeux
Olympique alors ça fait maintenant 4 ans
que nous travaillons chaque année sur le
thème des Jeux Olympiques c'est quand
même quelque
chose de gigantesque qui va mettre la
fête dans toutes nos nos nos villes ça
fait 4 ans que le thème de la fête de la
ville est sur les Jeux Olympiques avec
des spécificités on avait fait la
première année sur les Jeux Olympiques
maises vision jeux vidéo d'accord et on
a à chaque fois comme ça décliné chaque
chaque année une thématique on a surtout
beaucoup travailler ça avec les jeunes
dans les écoles et notamment c'est la
création des CIR Olympiades puisqueon
voilà on peut pas c'est quoi les CIR
Olympiades al les CIR Olympiades c'est
le nom qu'on a trouvé pour ne pas
utiliser de de term qui nous auraiit
coûté de l'argent d'accord voilà donc
c'est quoi c'est simplement revisiter
les Jeux Olympiques à travers à la fois
la pratique sport
mais surtout les les valeurs du sport
des Jeux Olympiques et les travailler
avec nos jeunes à la fois nos jeunes
dans nos élémentaires mais aussi et dans
nos materneles mais aussi
avec la fin du cycle qui se termine au
collège avec la 6e et le faire dans
l'ensemble de la ville on a la chance à
s'inir d'avoir un territoire qui est
très riche notamment d'avoir cette école
militaire en plein centre-ville et et
c'est l'occasion une fois par an de
faire entrer nos élèves nos écoles dans
le lycée militaire ser quand c'est sur
olympiade alors c'est c'est au mois de
juin
d'accord première quinzaine me
semble-t-il et c'est l'occasion en effet
de de faire entrer nos élèves dans le
lycée militaire de les faire travailler
sur les valeurs du sport du dépassement
de soi du fait de travailler en équipe
et beaucoup aussi sur le paralympique
parce qu'on a une fchuse tendance à tous
beaucoup parler des Jeux olympiques mais
c'est aussi un moment important voilà où
on peut se se permettre de parler de la
différence alors Sonia il vous reste à
peu près 30 secondes pour votre carte
blanche on vous laisse le sujet de votre
choix qu'est-ce que vous voulez aborder
et bien justement moi sur ma carte
blanche j'aimerais parler à la fois du
paralympique et ça tombe bien on
rebondit mais surtout de tout ce qui est
autour de de l'enfance de la différence
et du handicap j'aimerais d'abord
remercier mes services à la fois mes
services mais aussi l'éducation
nationale pour l'excellent travail qui
est fait sur notre commune je je
rappelle qu'il y a une loi en 2005 qui
dit qu'on doit inclure les enfants
différents que les moyens ont pas été
donnés et que voilà il faut aujourd'hui
vraiment développer cette partie-là on a
plus les moyens de de les mettre de côté
il faut vraiment les inclure ça passe
par des ai des centres de loisirs
adaptés à leur accueil ça passe par
beaucoup de formation au niveau à la
fois de nos enseignants mais aussi de
nos animateurs et voilà donc si ma carte
blanche devait être quelque chose
puisque nous sommes en 2024 et que nous
avons les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pensons à nos élèves
pensons à nos enfants plus pour
l'inclusion merci beaucoup Sonia breux
et encore une belle une belle année 2024
à saincir l'école c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur tv78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]